heard that there were real problems on  this set including discharges of two  live rounds people walking off the set  saying it was unsafe they didn't want to  work there did Baldwin know about this  and did he do anything about it  well we believe Baldwin as a producer  knows everything that goes on on the set  and so that yeah there was a lot of  problems there was a lot of there are a  couple accidental discharges there was a  lot of safety concerns that were brought  to the attention of management and and  he did nothing about it so there were  just this was a loose and Reckless scene  where safety was compromised just to  save money hey Sean Hannity here hey  click here to subscribe to Fox News  YouTube page and catch our hottest  interviews and most compelling analysis  you will not get it anywhere else